citizens of the reject Nation we are back here
today because we got ourselves a trailer another
one for this is a flash so of course join
with John Humphrey John how are you I am
super excited sir Koi Koi chandro flashtastic
ready to go follow koi on social media he lives
and breathes it like a monstrosity what is that
thing called in Man of Steel again my God the
world engine he is like the world engine just
sucking up all the hate comments all the real
supervillains if you can do me a solid just to
be a great favor if you could just do this for
me if you could speed on over to that like button
and just like the flash that would be amazing I'm
so excited for this movie because James Gunn will
not stop talking about it speaking of James Gunn
and Guardians of the Galaxy I'm transitioning
here ladies and gentlemen you guys remember a
couple months ago John can't be a Christian
Harlow and I we teamed up at Flappers comedy
live in Burbank to talk Ant-Man and the lost
Quantum Mania spoilers it was one of the best
moments of my YouTube career ended up talking
with so many fans during the show and after it
was such a highlight so we thought we'd re-team
again for Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. so on
Sunday May 7th 5 o'clock p.m we are returning
to Flappers tickets are now available we've
already been selling and it's been going great
but also if you can't make it in person which
is the ideal way to go you're also going to be
having pay-per-view links as well so you can
stream in love to have you in attendance guys
are you ready for this last trailer let's go
[Music]
I lost my parents
we know
made me who I am a whole lifetime
trying to right the wrongs of the past
as if fighting crime would bring my parents
back cool most of that is him right yeah it
must be you actually did it oh [__] you
actually did I can't imagine what you've
been through suit looks great moving I love you
monkey you lost both parents in one day very
I went back in time to time just for my parents
but instead I completely broke the universe
this world must die you changed the future
stands for
it's hope right how did you know
that I will help you if I thought
you want to get nuts
sweets two flashes right there confirmed
I have to undo what I did
guardrail gotta let her go I think it's who
we are I'm about to go back and fix them yes
a Metro tragedy to find you
man this is so harrowing
oh
awesome yeah
Batman consonant look at him go
do We're not gonna be it's this
interesting damn holy [__] awesome yes
[Music] that's great that's great you're
strapped to your parachutes and where's yours
a Batman [Music] no so much bad symbolism oh right
in front of the Moon Man how beautiful gorgeous
film love it I love that hell and the Flash dude
is so pretty every time I think we should go frame
by frame ladies and gentlemen I think we should
remember the first time we saw the trailer we
didn't know for sure if this was him but this must
be him when they first show up and then he gets a
bitching billionaire haircut that's how it's done
so that way he can look like that that's right be
a whole montage where he's crying as they're
cutting his hair it looks like fanfic brought
to life it just gives you so much joy of nostalgia
okay so these suits think they're all the same but
that blue and gray is so perfect on the left which
one this one yeah yeah second from the left I hope
we see it in action me too what's so great about
this particular shows the first one was so fun
this leaned more on that grief element that Barry
is struggling with and I loved the identification
that they hone in on with both Batman and the
Flash uh equality that you know they both lost
their parents a very superhero quality to you
have to endure this really shows you that heart
that I feel like Andy muschietti would be actually
great at bringing a life while bringing spectacle
into the equation too because at the end of the
day what makes a lot of these superhero movies
when they're truly great is having that level of
emotion and heart and I thought this trailer honed
in on that perfectly and the dichotomy between
Batman like going towards grief and Vengeance
and eventually him getting towards optimism and
hope I love that Barry is so optimistic through
this and he I mean he like he says he succeeds
he did save his parents through fighting crime
but then he has to unwrite it he has to undo the
thing Batman's always tried to do but we know
he's not going to we know he'll make the right
call in the end he's going to shoot his mom in
the head of his bare hands to undo the success he
has to end the thing that was the accomplishment
that's brutal one and for as much of a meme as
it is of it like oh man this is shaping up to
be a real Batman movie like it does make a lot
of thematic sense and I'm excited for how they
hone in more personally on that debate between
the two of them about you know what to do with
a timeline and you know holding on to that memory
of your parents to such a degree that you would
go to this extent did we get a look at the speed
force before in the last trailer I think really
briefly this is much longer look we can see the
Matrix like bullet time around it which I don't
think we saw yeah I'm trying to see if we can
catch any little glimpses in here as I remembered
and like what is this thing forming right there
at the end is he just uh I look like a it looks
like a little ghost of him I could I couldn't
tell if it was like a creature or something
like that turning into a phoenix but I do think
there's a symbolism right here or it looks like
it looks like an actual design of something
is appearing right here he's passing through
a Sonic ring that's also I would say in this we're
going to see a lot of flashes of Elder multiverses
though I think we're just they're cutting away but
there's going to be images I think we're going to
get other worlds in that sequence yeah one at
the very end it has the blue Lightning so I
wonder if that's like symbolic of this flash with
the yellow lightning arriving in the timeline I'm
almost familiar with or something like that
oh that makes sense and the classic slide is
so great I love that yeah these look like iMac
shots seriously I recognize an IMAX camera and
the recontextualization of all the Man of Steel
stuff is a really cool like going really in depth
with that in this trailer is I didn't realize like
how much this is going to be sort of like oh just
on the other side of this situation you know not
to open it up because I'm scared to but what if
this is so good not only do they keep Ezra but
it does allow for the Snyder world to exist as a
parallel timeline because this looks like it could
either end it or allow for it which is interesting
well the one thing that I'm really hoping for
that they do here is because Zod looks like the
bad guy again and it feels like this is you know
they're they're doing Man of Steel remake at this
point but I'm wondering if the movie will allow
time to flesh out Zod or have Zod be something
different or interesting because you're gonna kind
of compare his presence here to what he did at Man
of Steel and he's just gonna be is did they just
bring back Michael Shannon to rehash you know what
he already did but on a much smaller level and
when looking at the destruction because it's like
this is the destruction within the city but later
on in the trailer and especially this moment looks
like they they fight actually out in the desert
yeah where there are no people yeah smart call
Smart call sociality learning from the message
boards that line again to have uh Supergirl say
hope is is or imply that's the symbol is
wonderful because I I really think there's
a presence to her I'm excited to see on screen
oh yeah I mean there's even these tight little
glimpses she just looks like such an intense
character at least in this representation and
I can't wait to see what Sasha Kelly does with it
it's pretty cool that they brought this line back
your Felix one I love it because it gives me the
warmth but two it what he says that it's Bruce
Wayne and it's at the Joker it's out of context
it makes no sense logically but it's okay cause
it's fun I don't know who he's saying it to
not the Joker I wonder if it's because in the
flashpoint comic is when uh you know Batman tries
to help him get his powers back Barry Allen ah the
electricity scenes that I've seen because it seems
like through it it is circumstances that at some
point both of them will have powers both berries
will have the flash Powers um and I wonder if
that's what he's talking about is like I'm gonna
strike you yeah I'm gonna raise you into my bat
Frankenstein you know Inspire yeah because yeah
you got like two very different flash suits here I
love them roided out one it's got a bat cowl flash
she's wearing a bat suit painted red yeah and he's
got the yellow like that's basically a street sign
drawn on so this is bat flash on the right so I
assume this is The Flash this is our Flash from
Man of Steel time yeah and he's imported into the
world and that's the suit he borrows because those
are the ABS from Batman Returns and he's got the
blue Lightning and he's got the yellow lightning
which is the release Credence to your theory about
the lightning Landing yeah and Credence good uh
reference to another Ezra Miller character ah
slowing this footage down Supergirl's taking Barry
up I I wonder if she's trying to help him get his
powers here I wonder if it fails in the Batman
version yeah and Supergirl brings him straight to
the source I'm like why the hell is she bringing
him up to the sky straight straight into the
stratosphere um we need to find the nearest
thunderstorm we got lightning in there too so
I feel like he's he's trying to help him get his
powers back there or he dies and they have to jolt
him back to life like it he looks very unconscious
like like he dies doing the experimental way and
she has to bring him up and it gets to work
oh yeah yeah yeah we need more lightning
Organics like free range lightning and the blue
and orange here is gorgeous just from like a
visual aesthetic style because you've got all
these blue and oranges with the two flashes but
the explosion here with the Kryptonian technology
in the Earth Technology clashing so you've got
blue and orange this force field you got blue and
orange the explosion you've got like this is just
gorgeous yeah it's true a nice thematic earmark
yeah this looks freaking torturous he was trying
to get his powers back and in Flashpoint they
have to do it a few times so it's going to be
rough when I do appreciate appreciate the in
this imagery they do keep still some of that
Snyder aesthetic like especially when he's
screaming and being Zapped by lightning like
that looks like something straight out of zsjl
or something like that you know so even though
it's not like clear that that's still part of
the universe they're still homogening it pretty
heavily that's why I'm wondering if they're going
to keep the universe going through this and and
like I was talking about the multiple flashes
here I love that they've a long-haired flash
symbolizing one ideal of Flash and then the
short air flash but you've also got that with
the Batmans like we just saw Ben Affleck talking
about his grief and his experience then we've got
Michael Keaton on his knees soon thereafter so the
duality of Batman's with the way vengeance is what
they became but the berries optimism is what he
became so you you've got a vengeful long-haired
Berry and then you've got Arbury who discovers
hope through adversity but Batman never found
that fully which is a really beautiful dichotomy
between a pair of flashes and a pair of bats
yeah you know what uh Batman would totally
die in this fight I don't care what anyone
says but it's cool looking I took care
of it he's got three there's several
kryptonians yeah he didn't even totally
died this guy's like 90. and he's like yeah
this guy would survive oh In This
Moment here oh yeah doing the doing
the Locust film bumper version of all
the different uh uh Justice League logos
and then the error cut will be the post-credits
scene it'll be great did you catch that look
at that oh 100 that was I was focused on Batman
diving there oh yeah that moonshot is gorgeous uh
that's a great shot yeah well that's straight from
the 89 movie yeah and and this has so much of both
the movie history of the Batman stories but also
it just has so many shots that really feel like
that Darth Gothic dark Gothic comic book sort of
vibe too along with all the stuff that hearkens to
the Snyder works and moshietti I said it was the
first trailer but he grabs a comic frame and makes
it happen and he did Tim Burton with Batman he's
doing Snyder win his cider scenes but also the
mushitti's clearer in this trailer like you said
with the grief there's a lot more of mushitti's
Style mixed with Snyder's mixed with Burtons to
make this great splash page stunning all right
guys well what'd you think about this trailer
for The Flash are you excited are you prepared to
read all the leaks that come out after Cinema con
already airs is for so many people are you ready
to mute every single related word on Twitter guys
get ready for it Jesus well leave your thoughts
down below uh be sure to subscribe leave a like
if you want to attend uh the event that I'm doing
that would be very much appreciated follow this
guy on social media I'll see you guys soon [Music]